se vuelven a Elevar las tensiones entre
las potencias mundiales debido a la
guerra en Ucrania tras los recientes
ataques rusos sobre territorio ucraniano
organismos internacionales Están
preocupados ante la escalada de la
ofensiva y hay temores ante un
eventuales recrudecimiento a nivel
nuclear está aumentando este riesgo pues
lo vamos a analizar con nuestro primer
invitado al día Julián gadano director
del programa de estudios en energía
nuclear e Innovación de la Universidad
Nacional 3 de febrero entre 2015 y 2019
fue subsecretario energía nuclear de la
República Argentina Gracias Julián por
estar con nosotros una vez más en
directo América de Francia 24 que tan
cerca estamos de digamos este riesgo
nuclear que enfrentamos tras el
conflicto que estamos viendo actualmente
en Ucrania este recrudecimiento por
parte de Vladimir Putin
bien bueno ante todo gracias por la
invitación Gracias nuevamente es un
placer estar aquí con ustedes y con su
audiencia
el riesgo es un poquito mayor es un
poquito superior a hace dos meses a la
última vez que estuvimos juntos aquí en
el en su canal sin embargo esto no
significa suponer que es inminente
analicemos un poquito el escenario Putin
está en una situación no prevista por él
el 24 de febrero cuando invadió
se encuentra digamos estancado en una
guerra que esperaba resolver rápidamente
como la guerra de crimea y no la resolví
como cuando tomó la Península de crimea
y no la resolvió y lo que está haciendo
al estar acorralado pensemos que estar
acorralado para Putin implica
literalmente una situación de vida y
muerte o muerte no no puede por las
características la gobernanza rusa para
Putin no es una opción volver sin una
victoria
y ese escenario que lo tiene acorralado
lo lleva a mostrarle al mundo a
recordarle al mundo que es el líder de
una potencia nuclear sí recordemos que
países con armas nucleares hay nueve en
el mundo pero el 90% de los arsenales
están en manos de Estados Unidos o Rusia
entonces toma varias digamos hace varias
cosas al mismo tiempo primero
anexa las cuatro provincias ucranianas
que pretende tomar porque eso las vuelve
las pone en línea las anexa en una
anexión absolutamente no que el mundo
jamás reconocerá por supuesto
ilegítima etcétera no quiero entrar en
eso pero con eso él está dando un
mensaje a occidente le está diciendo a
partir de ahora yo voy a considerar el
territorio este territorio como
territorio ruso eso le habilita el
acceso al armamento nuclear de acuerdo a
la doctrina militar nuclear rusa que
solo habilita usar el armamento nuclear
cuando territorio ruso se ve amenazado
Entonces ahora Putin le está diciendo
occidente cuidado porque ahora nosotros
vamos a considerar esto territorio ruso
número uno número dos se filtra
información
de que digamos va de está desplegando
submarinos nucleares etcétera son todos
mensajes que da que hace que sea lógico
que el presidente de los Estados Unidos
diga que estamos en la peor crisis
nuclear de la crisis de los misiles en
Cuba desde el año 1962 pero no significa
digamos para que no entendemos en pánico
que se va a usar el armamento nuclear
pasado mañana digamos no me parece que
eso vaya a ocurrir claro Julián y eso le
quería preguntar precisamente se cumplen
60 años de esta crisis de los misiles en
la que estabas hablando no Qué tan lejos
cerca estamos de esa crisis o sea
haciendo un balance de estos 60 años y
con esa guerra en Ucrania además
Rescatando las palabras del presidente
estadounidense ellos bailan que fueron
que fueron bastante fuertes bastante
contundentes digamos por la información
que maneja imagino yo pero también la
Casa Blanca luego salió matizar un poco
estas declaraciones del presidente yo
bailén como para no evidentemente
generar pánico porque la gente Realmente
está por lo que está pasando en esta
guerra y pues el mayor temor de todos
nosotros creo que es evidentemente un
enfrentamiento nuclear que ya sabemos
como lo como lo estabas comentando que
que no es tan fácil no digamos de de
entrar en una guerra nuclear creo que
también ningún mandatario Quiere pasar a
la historia como lo hemos hablado aquí
durante todos estos meses de guerra con
analistas como el que empezó una guerra
nuclear destructiva digamos no pero pero
volviendo a ese tema de los 60 años de
los misiles eh Cómo hace el balance
Bueno yo creo que Efectivamente es
estrictamente Es cierto que estamos es
el momento es la crisis más grave
respecto del de estar cerca de una
guerra nuclear desde el 62
fecha la que efectivamente están por
cumplir 60 años ahora o se han cumplido
ya Perdón ahora no significa que estemos
tan cerca como en ese momento en ese
momento tú se tuvo muy cerca era un
escenario guerra fría con las dos
potencias con misil desplegados
apuntando hacia la otra con Estados
Unidos demostrando claramente que no
estaba dispuesto a cuidar misiles en
Cuba con misiles desplegados en Turquía
bueno otro escenario estamos lejos de
ese escenario ahora Estamos un poquito
más cerca de ese escenario que hace dos
meses
digamos Qué significa básicamente que
Rusia ha puesto sobre la mesa la
posibilidad de que esto ocurra y la
respuesta de Estados Unidos ha sido
correcta ha sido primero decirle no me
voy no voy a dejarme correr no nos vamos
a dejar correr por tu amenaza es un
juego de la gallina que están jugando
los dos ya vamos a ver quién no es la
gallina digamos y al mismo tiempo mandé
un mensaje doméstico al interior
diciendo no es que nosotros vamos a usar
y responsablemente el armamento nuclear
qué saco yo de estas declaraciones del
presidente viven que si Putin se
atreviera a usar armamento claro aunque
sea táctico aunque sea pequeño aunque
sea de poca carga la reacción
estadounidense va a ser cualitativamente
superior muy superior a lo que vemos hoy
sin significar necesariamente que vaya a
ser nuclear yo creo que Estados Unidos
tiene mucho para hacer antes de usar su
propio Arsenal que es entrar en una
escalada de la que no sabemos cómo se va
a salir puede usar mucho armamento
convencional puede meter soldados de la
otan puede atacar territorio ruso puede
hacer un montón de cosas hay un montón
de cosas todavía previas a usar
armamento nuclear Por eso yo sigo
pensando Sin tener la bola de cristal
por supuesto y entendiendo que el
liderazgo de Putin es muy irresponsable
a nivel internacional Sigo pensando que
todavía estamos un poquito lejos de una
crisis con uso de armamento nuclear
estamos más cerca que hace dos meses y
Julián hablando esta y responsabilidad
digamos y volatilidad de como se ha
mostrado el Vladimir Putin sobre todo
durante estos últimos siete meses de
guerra de quién depende la decisión para
realmente usar el armamento nuclear así
sea táctico no y pues evidentemente que
antes de atacar una una una ciudad o lo
que sea pues hay unos pasos que que
hacen los gobiernos tácticamente no para
decir no te me sigas metiendo conmigo
porque si ahora voy a usar el armamento
nuclear a contra un objetivo bien
importante dentro de tu territorio no
hablemos un poco de este proceso bien
bien Es que es muy pregunta porque
Además eso Esas información que la
inteligencia de los países tienen sobre
los otros entonces Rusia Más allá de las
declaraciones digamos explosivas valga
el uso del término triste por cierto de
su presidente no ha cambiado su
condición de defensa decir no activado
alertas no ha puesto en condición de
digamos previa al lanzamiento lo que se
llama condición activa su Arsenal no ha
desplegado los hilos no ha desplegado de
manera ofensiva sus aviones no ha puesto
sus aviones en condición de despegue Hay
un montón de cosas que no ha hecho y que
la inteligencia norteamericana conoce si
lo hiciera que no descartemos que lo
haga porque forma parte este finalmente
un juego militar es si me permiten el
término es una conversación también es
decir Yo hice esto qué vas a hacer tú yo
hice ahora esto Rusia no ha desplegado
para decirlo simple no ha desple su
equipamiento nuclear a un nivel tal que
el próximo paso es lanzarlo no lo ha
hecho no ha desplegado su condición de
defensa no ha desplegado sus sus aviones
no ha pegado submarinos si lo hiciera
Estados Unidos le diría claramente que
estamos en otra instancia además de eso
técnicamente para activar un armamento
nuclear se necesita del concurso de más
de una persona Claro sí no puede Putin
por su cuenta dar una orden necesita
activar una llave que hoy es una llave
electrónica y otra llave más debe ser
activada sabe que está en posesión del
ministro de defensa y del jefe el
comandante supremo de fuerzas armadas
una debería esperar siendo tan vertical
el liderazgo en Rusia que no tendría
tanta dificultades Pero bueno hay que
estar dispuesto a hacer eso y después
están las activaciones a nivel operativo
es decir el capitán o mayor que tiene
que lanzar el cohete yo creo que estamos
todavía un poquito lejos de eso